[Music]
ten years ago I would say that Chinese
economy didn't really matter to American
consumers into American market well as
you saw when Apple made this
announcement then their stock dropped
10% the Pearl market came down about 3%
there used to be a saying in 1980s that
when America coughs the rest of the
world catches cold and today it seems to
me that when China's sneezes the the
rest of the world at least the coughs so
it's relevant and it's important and
therefore it's important to understand
it I think understanding its most recent
history as I explained in my book out of
the Gobi will be useful
you wouldn't want to get into a market
without knowing anything about it what
is the most deceiving thing about China
is that growth doesn't necessarily
translate into profitability if you look
at the Chinese stock market which
started around 1992 so by now we are
talking about 20 27 years right and in
that 27 years China's economy has grown
can you guess by how much it has grown
by 30 times in nominal terms 30 times in
27 years if you had invested in China's
stock market from very beginning 1992
and you you have held here investment
for all these years never got out during
which the economy has grown by 30 times
how much money do you think you will
have
made a semester you will have lost money
right people would ask why not is case
now there is not a strong correlation
between the stock market and economic
performance at any given moment however
over a long period of time I say 20
years in every country there is positive
correlation between economic growth and
stock market performance and China is a
single exception you know I'm hurt some
investors telling me and we're in the
investment business we are in private
equity business so we have many
investors who trust us with their money
to invest in Asia particularly in China
they say well China now is second
largest economy in the world America is
artists and I allocate 40 percent of my
capital to America I should allocate at
least 30 percent to China just by the
sheer size of the economy and I would
tell them a story about how China has
grown in the past 20-some years how the
stock market would actually give them a
negative return and then you look into
the question why that is the case it is
it has to do with China's economic
growth model driven so much by
investments and therefore yes earnings
have been growing in aggregate in China
and the capital base with which you
produce their earnings has been growing
even faster because China has invested
so much and therefore our o e or return
on capital and may be falling and if you
don't understand it if you invest just
in economic growth you don't understand
that there's a bad economy with a lot of
overcapacity and there's a good economy
which is actually growing then you're
bound to make mistakes
[Music]